welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast a lie what up
today's episode is sponsored by the
elderscrolls legends quip and Teddy
fresh oh wow but that's us that's us my
friends we have for you today planned a
cringe miss miracle and by miracle I
mean disaster arrangements cringe miss I
mean take from that what you will
we were scheduled to have Tommy Wiseau
today and unfortunately due to
scheduling or whatever happens in
people's lives you could not make it but
it was serendipitous so I say that right
serendipitous I don't know I'm missing
an accent there it was serendipitous
anyway because we were planning this
huge h3 video about Jake and Logan
Paul's merch machine the church of merch
oh my god I have the culture sure I
forgot to wear it right it's okay I can
channel it spiritually we were planning
on HD to make this huge Logan and Jake
Paul video because the way that they
plugged their merch has evolved before
like during the the everyday bro period
when they first exact I won when they
first started it was cheeky it was cute
like hey God Church merch weak wink buy
my merch but it's actually transformed
into something a little bit more
nefarious a little bit more dark and
manipulative predatory even in my in my
opinion and since the Christmas season
came it was such a big season for them
the way that they marketed it was really
something to behold so I was putting
together chronology and all the ways
that they marketing their merch recently
but we're leaving on the 31st to go
visit Ella's family in Israel and we
just don't have the time to do it so I
we put together all this content all
these videos and we said hey this this
will work in the podcast format anyway
so today
we have for you a an extravaganza a
study this kept put your cringe suits on
but it's more than that there's
something interesting here that I think
is worth taking a closer look at so
that's what we're up to today
now this like I was saying just to touch
on something really brief this is the
last episode of season one I like to
call it season two we're coming back on
what day would come back the 19th I
think of January we'll be back and I'm
and I'm really seriously toying with the
idea of coming back strong season 2
thinking about maybe doing five shows a
week bring on a writer
why get serious as hell what I would
love what I would love and I'm again I'm
not this isn't final I'm just toying
with the idea maybe you guys can bounce
some ideas but like keep the interview
once a week on Friday I then have like
30 minute episodes every other day of
the week where we tackle some topic
every day something that's come up with
in this case we're talking about this
merch machine I think one day a week
should be about shredder one day put on
shredder Karen please okay so yeah we've
maybe five all five days about shredder
yeah
you lose obsessed for sure how are you
gonna live without shredder for eight
days nine days ten days anyway so let's
begin this is gonna be interesting for
me so you guys know Jake and Logan Paul
as the cringy child entertainer
goofballs that they've been they've
they've owned this year on YouTube and
I'm not I can't mince words and I can't
deny them any credit those guys hustle
they work hard they shredded they shred
they're savages by the way they also
ruin everything I love well I don't say
I love savages but they they ruin things
Savage you can't use that
word anyone dabbing I think Logan Paul
single-handedly killed daddy daddy was
like cool for a minute like rappers were
dabbing and now all the sudden Logan's
like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna have all my
eight-year-old white kids dabbing and
they're like double dad you just see him
on video he said this is still funny is
it lit hey I saw that in the chat lit he
ruined he ruined Gucci yeah
Logan's walking around in Gucci and it's
like bro you you if I was good she I
wouldn't I would make it a policy Tesla
it's not just him but they killed Tesla
as well I have I mean he'll I got a
Tesla I'm thinking about returning it
but it's not just him every it seems
like it's the YouTube dish doucher car
these days I'm gonna buy a Tesla I
bought it because I care about electric
vehicles I wanted to help
Elon in his mission to protect humanity
I'm returning it I'm returning all my
sisters with savage on it to which you
have zero oh I had a ton of savage stuff
before if I was saying if I was gay I
would make it a policy not to sell to
them what do you mean that's kind of
know that we would probably fall in that
same category I don't that's why we met
that's why we're like Gucci clothing I
think it's cool but we're like don't
what would they say we don't sell it to
youtubers fine whatever just whatever
whatever it takes man just get it off
him all right but so not that anyone can
even afford that's it yeah it's like
come on he's walking around in one of
these videos with like a ten thousand
dollar Gucci like denim jacket I love
their clothing it's ridiculously priced
but I admire what they're doing it's
really cool
take it off bro you ruined the brand you
just did millions of all these rappers
there they're returning the Gooch I have
a tracksuit you guys saw it from the
vapenation
and 150 battery ma'am I burned it but
something's changed something has
changed they used to be cheeky and cute
about selling merch and what I think has
happened is that they're so competitive
with each other and they share the same
fans that they're having like the
psychological warfare they're each being
forced to ramp up how aggressively they
sell merch to top the other one because
they're there competing for the same
audience the same kids and they're all
have this identity crisis of I'm reject
Paul or I'm a SAP I'm a maverick Logan
Logan so they're stepping it up
possibly unconsciously in a way and it's
come to the point where they're
basically telling kids throw out the
[ __ ] your parents bought you and I'm not
making something yeah and one of the
videos will watch logan paul says throw
out whatever [ __ ] santé aka your parents
bought you and pick up this maverick
merch and the more maverick mercs you
have is how much my love increases for
you it's like it reminds me of this some
show I love Nathan for you he has this
bit where he has he's trying to market
this toy and if you don't know the
premise of the show he does these really
ridiculous unpractical solutions
offensive in some ways and he's got this
toy that won't sell so he has all these
kids in at a table about eight same
[ __ ] ages these guys as fans and he's
like so this toy everyone who doesn't
have this toy is a baby the only way
that you can be a big boy is if you have
this toy and so he gives it one to one
to everyone except one kid he's like do
you feel like a baby you're a baby right
now do you want this toy and the kids
like yeah that's what they're doing gosh
they're like and another thing before we
get into the videos that I want you guys
to focus on there they become like
YouTube mobsters they started to churn
out these music videos and the point of
a music video is usually to entertain to
provide a song and a dance right but
what they're doing is
these these are essentially more
commercial and to sell their March than
it is to entertain and so they're doing
a kind of like a double a double take
like you show up to the storefront
pretending that they're selling a jeans
once you you know blow out the candles
and close the blinds and when mommy's
not in the room it's crack it's not an
actual crack it's metaphorical crack
which is much scarier you'll see what I
mean it's it's all about their merch and
there's almost no content left and the
craziest part is at the end of these
songs they still go by this song on
iTunes it's like buying a Taco Bell
jingle for some [ __ ] on iTunes
it's like demolition man if you guys
have seen that so let's just you know
and let me just say also there's nothing
wrong with merchandise I mean especially
in these days a merchandise is the
lifeblood of a lot of youtubers it's
huge for us particularly and a lot of
other people but when it becomes the
entire body of your work and the soul of
everything you do it becomes strange and
especially when you're selling it to
kids who don't have their own money and
you're saying [ __ ] like tell your mom
like I'm this is a lyric you wanna tell
your mom buy everything in my store and
throw out throw out your other [ __ ] it's
good it crosses into Scientology like
levels of weird cultish vibes so it mic
thesis here is that there's some brain
there's some legitimate brainwashing
going on
it's very predatory on these kids and
they're selling like garbage there's
this one I want to show you I don't want
to ruin the surprise but some of this
merch will just drop your jaw so let's
start I've got a game plan here let's
see how far they've strayed from God's
light or as Jake Paul would say from God
church's light it's been a while since
we have goofed on the old blind boy
Logan Paul so let's start there this is
around six months ago
same time that everyday bro blew up and
I think I've been around that time
everybody started understanding that you
turn out these music videos and it's
like this insane
easy to produce money machine because
they sell the song they plugged the
merch and it's like this whole thing it
is crazy they get so many views every
day bro what are the views on that let
me know that was that was a bit of a
phenomenon but a lot of them I remember
that was like on the top charts on
iTunes too but this video has 160
million that's crazy
yeah I mean that that's pop star numbers
yeah so I don't know let's let's start
with here you guys know that one so I'm
not gonna bother showing that to you
this one is special to me called Logan
is my hero let's pull this up this has
42 Mille Miglia I'm not gonna make fun
of this kid he's a sweet-ass kid I don't
want to say anything bad about this poor
there's sweet beautiful wonderful child
he's sweet and I love him to bits right
EULA so I'm gonna cut out this whole I
don't understand that I haven't done the
research maybe I'm missing something but
why does why does Logan look like a
[ __ ] lesbian in the shot but what is
going on with this look bro why do you
look like Ellen's cousin why do you look
like your own mother it's weird
but anyway that's I guess that's uh so
this this can't made a video about how
hey Logan you're my hero god bless
I want to they're always Melbourne merch
you don't have a focus music video of 27
feet okay so this kid made a music video
about Logan hey you're my hero and he's
like this is cool I'm gonna fly him out
and make a music video together okay so
this is the result and this is from six
months ago this is before this is when
there was still a flicker of light in
his eyes he's getting completely fallen
into the chasm the black death chasm
from like the newest Star Wars movie mmm
the Dark Side chasm that's where he's
fallen into no it's a fact that everyone
has a hero yeah yeah and sometimes when
you're tickled just the right way you
gotta make a dumb ass song about it fact
so this is that dumb ass song that will
fact and guess what the fact I'm feeling
tickled yeah yeah I saw this video
saying though before we get deep into
this it's also worth remembering that
all the life he wrote this song cuz
there's a lot of dick sucking of him
being like you're the wisest you're the
coolest and he's like really you think
so it's like yeah but you wrote this
line about yourself Hogan you're my hero
saying I'm the man like I'm some type of
Robert De Niro I don't know why though
this kid looks like he's shy though but
he talked that track like a gosh
dreamz why they so obsessed with that
amazing oh my gosh I missed that I
missed that
I'm so sorry I interrupted this
incredible my favorite the joke that I
was hanging out with posts and his
brother Jordan and Jordan had a really
funny observation he's like Logan is
like the stereotypical white rapper that
everyone makes fun of who's like hi my
name is Logan and I'm here to say buy my
merch or else you're gay which is
essentially what this song blows down to
that's amazing that's amazing
was that good should I put on paper so
write that down down write that down
with you copy
okay bro
oh he green screens out the pool and
puts in Martin Luther King jr. can you
think of a more tasteless thing like but
here take the whole thing and as a body
but I'm not saying that he's not are you
not saying that he's not Martin Luther
King because that kid is not Martin
Luther King empirically so and then look
like bro poor MLK can't rest in peace
they green-screen his ass in the [ __ ]
back of the stare with his ass like
grinning it's disturbing also and okay
it's just like the weirdest comparison
ever this is probably the anything you
can go
I was relevant to this kid's life look
at this okay
so funny I'm not saying that it is but
I'm not saying that he isn't I think
it's not what are you saying he might
yeah what do you say you're you're
essentially saying that you're not
saying anything I'm not saying just drop
my Martin Martin's name and okay let's
try and get some street cred here dude
is Martin Luther King he's gonna KITT
you know he's gonna do he's gonna ruin
Martin Luther King for everybody we have
to erase him from the history books I
think the next one is also yeah he's
gonna start selling merch with MLK face
on it
maybe you're the next MLK be a maverick
a maverick he would have been if he was
alive today
I don't know now who are you to say that
this kid I am okay only the cold yeah I
just think the comparison to MLK and
Kanye is just double bizarre double fact
double dab double bizarre okay who are
you to say that this kid ain't MLK or
even Kanye by the way notice how they
they key in [ __ ] here's MLK
delivering his speech for Logan Paul to
sell merch okay yeah they put his ass in
the back Phil can you even tell her what
is that it's the most tasteless [ __ ]
I've ever seen in my life
this kid doesn't do anything either look
at him just he's like cool I can't I
don't say I'm not making fun of the kid
he's a sweetheart
I love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
just remember you wrote this okay I'm
sorry I don't mean Ciro people [ __ ] I
don't know the people need heroes and I
don't know that they need to make songs
with the heroes it's weird it's a little
creepy you worship me I worship this guy
he writes in the lyrics you worship me
I'm your hero
the insinuation that he would ever
answer his phone if this could have
called him and cracked me up as if he's
got like a giant presidential phone that
plugs him right through you know he gets
text from him and he's just like ignore
I'm sorry dude
hit me up hit me up if you ever need
advice that's where it gets like
tasteless and this is six months ago so
he still has some soul left but it's
like alarmingly tasteless because he's
making this wholesome song with this kid
and I also wouldn't criticize it if it
wasn't for the mirch undertones
he's making this wholesome song
celebrating this kid he flew him out but
then all of a sudden his this kid is an
accessory he becomes like a pawn an
actor and then someone's like the fact
that is Wade this kid is using it as a
shield like you can't criticize him
because he made a nice act exam thinking
like he's probably gonna look at us like
oh look at them how dare you make fun of
me I did this wonderful thing for this
kid who could ever talk [ __ ] about me
this was a wonderful thing but he's
using this kid as an actor he's using
him in an advertisement and he's saying
okay now at this point of the movie the
video I'm gonna hand you this mervich
maverick sweater and you're gonna seem
super happy
what's his cut on that by the way does
he have any back does he owe me
royalties on this commercial but yeah
he's using he's using the kid and it
becomes less wholesome and and it's very
very tasteless this whole link in the
box but here it's really it's not that
bad yet we want to show this as where
things started right it's a it's a
little tasteless it's a it's a little
tasteless
right there's part where it's just like
part of the bit is him saying merch in
the background it gets bad it gets so
much worse than this but this is just a
chronology the goodbye everybody needs
someone to idolize
everybody needs someone to idolize I
think that's pretty unhealthy suggestion
I don't think that idolizing anyone is a
healthy all right and as someone's Idol
I don't think you need to fly them out
and write them lyrics of young kids or
basically on his knees worshipping you
as his hero yeah he's like you idolize
me that's great let me love that about
you
yeah capable doing that I don't know
anything about you but you idolize me
apparently all right listen you got a
full pizza there you're sharing the
slice what the why whatever we don't
need to the kids worse
why are you sure to slice
yeah so there's 30 love that there's a
lot to chew on here so this is when it
gets into kind of the brainwashing and I
know you might think I'm getting
ridiculous but but listen to how
ridiculous this is
and okay the fact that in his mind when
they're producing this song he has the
presence of mind to just throw in and he
does this throughout the song emerge
it's Bray I think it's brainwashing I
really do merge and like just you know
it happens several times throughout and
it's kind of hard to catch so it's
pretty it's pretty weird
but there's also something here I wanted
to comment on as well what are they
planning
how many 72 virgins in paradise are you
stopping crime or committing it hang
with virgins and paradise that's not
appropriate merch with a kid yeah let's
go hang with the cuties in Paris
let's go spit roast some cuties together
it's a little inappropriate but it's
insinuated merge merge you want to go
tag that was Judi I think we can move on
to the other stuff that was like the
under part Oh ela there's come on you're
gonna deprive everyone wanna finishing
this I'm trying to save people no this
is come on
[Music]
my man is a savage I can see it in his
eyes
you're really wise oh okay
he wrote this yeah Logan
you really wise also true double effect
merge merge merge merge merge merge okay
bro why does this look like a memorial
service that this kid just looked passed
away what the most inappropriate green
screen moment exactly it's like it's
like an obituary could show up right now
and be like child drowned at Logan
Paul's compound
he was overburdened by maverick merch
and sunk to the bottom like a bag of
dirt
rest in peace little guy okay why
seeking a rope just got back from
hanging out with the 72 virgins making
some sense back to the hero stuff let's
talk future tense in 13 to 20 years
we'll both be president yes so would you
talk
it's his rhyme they're super intelligent
and he's aware of it because he said
Secretary of Defense Oh daddy oh god
he's so wise oh I'd love to submit roast
someone won't blow him mm-hmm I love to
hang out with all the 72 virgins of like
look at this kid he looks confused he's
like what are you doing bro
there's no what I signed up for yeah I
came out to like make a music video not
a commercial here let me slow down when
can buy a look about it they're being
cheeky about it they lose the cheeky and
it's just aggressive that's that's the
point he's making
he's like software goofy and then it
just becomes aggressive like kill your
parents
steal their cards buy my merch whatever
it takes watch this [ __ ] he's like bro
what the hell
the way you merch raping me know the
kids I even smile he just keeps it looks
confused
[Music]
all right so we have got that one
squared away and once again this is a
starting point now let's move it on to
the next video which is Logan's one of
his recent Christmas tracks and I want
you to see the difference in aggression
here so this is called Santa dis track
and it has 31 million views it came out
December 10th this was basically yeah a
big a big push to plug his March air get
ready
gear up my friends by the way Jill Logan
Paul is one of his best friends as a
dwarf who's in a lot of his vlogs is it
PC to put a dwarf in a Santa's elf
costume is that oh is that something
people are I mean I just I'm asking the
last time I remember seeing that was
like bad Santa was I don't know bad so
anyway that's kind of interesting
observation this is so obscenely branded
he has maverick car cushions oh wow you
see the detail that went into this
that's like BJ collared level he's
approaching he's found quickly
approaching those levels of meme tum
ready relay this holy Sh holy bleep
Jose and Santa yeah Wow yeah he's a
maverick with the flip are you yeah
so though by the way this is completely
DJ College style yeah what happened bro
just thank you.thank rest in the DJ
Khaled five years ago I won I have a
weird thought on it's a conspiracy
theory but I wonder if the clothes he
makes is the same [ __ ] he sells I wonder
if this [ __ ] is like tailor fitted to
him to look better so they don't put
that much effort into a knot he looks
like full DJ Khaled Yeezy maverick style
[Music]
where's he going right now by the way I
was wondering so get some treehouse
spit-roast a couple of cuties in
paradise so he just he accuses mrs.
closet being a caucus entually mr. Claus
he just he cooked Santa said he [ __ ]
his wife twice he just he straight-up is
called a Santa a [ __ ] and this is for
kids yeah bro and he dropped the f-bomb
the first 30 seconds of this song is
like is like content you could consider
it like a song but it at at some point
it just completely devolves into
commercial
from the north but I'm from Ohio why so
obsessed with the fact that from hooha
Ohio why by Ohio I don't get it what's
that say that's me quoting Jake Paul
Kyoto bite my white boy so no my
feelings are not hurt it's pretty much
talking to you right now let me let me
have a good tile on button so my
feelings are not hurt it's just weird
and creepy bro and the fact that you had
the presence of mind to acknowledge that
you knew that it was creepy and weird
and stupid that's what you dressed it in
your own song and then here well this is
the course yeah okay that this is where
it gets creepy uh
take it take your gifts and give them
back maverick merch is where it's at was
essentially saying Santa Claus your
parents bought you a bunch of crap throw
it out you need maverick merch in this
whole like yeah I rep my merch like
that's his whole identity there's no
song left it's just all about like yes I
rep my merch it's cool to just sell [ __ ]
to you it's cool that my whole essence
in being is just surrounded about
selling you merch and somehow because
their fans are eight-year-olds and
probably actually eight-year-olds or
maybe 13 12 yeah 8 to 13 or 15 they they
don't have the presence of mind to
understand how weird this is they don't
have their own money and well here got
the hoodie got the Hat
[Music]
okay so again you should get my new
backpack throw away that their sack it's
just so funny that's like any pop song
about merch about maverick merch and
that's what I mean when I say like it's
a storefront they're pretending now to
be making music but it's actually just
like almost entirely a commercial and
it's super sneaky and manipulative he's
planting these ideas that your do
whatever you whatever you have that's
not maverick merch is garbage
whatever backpack you have this not
maverick is garbage let me show you by
the way I want to play a little game
here my friends cuz I where's my [ __ ]
Mouse here it is I'm gonna play a little
song okay now my friends let's play a
game
you should get my new backpack here is
uh to have the price on this this is a
jet we're playing a game but I've kind
of bad at this okay here here is the
exclusive gold maverick backpack by
logan paul guess the price everybody
take a guess at the cost of this
backpack dan do you have a guess
$200 you can't over guess you roll the
game when you / guess 20 bucks
good guess this maverick exclusive
backpack is being sold to kids for $100
i actually asked our production manager
the cost she estimated for teddy fresh
that it would cost about seven dollars
to make and not and not that that is
you're not allowed to upsell [ __ ] but
it's the fact that it's being sold to
kids who have no sense of quality who
are basically being told to beg their
parents to buy it for them and this
backpack I'm fairly sure will
disintegrate after one drop of rain hits
it well pretty much just evaporate
disintegrate thanks for playing guys
that was $100 and maverick gold
exclusive backpack and that's five star
reviews so gotta quit cuz it's not gonna
be around forever
you should get my new backpack [ __ ] you
say I don't want people to be like like
let me acknowledge yes we also sell 30
fresh and it's not cheap let me just get
that out of the way well it's it's all
fine they can sell the backpack for $100
it's just there's something about the
way they do it and who's the audience
it's kids that's the thing it's not
adults who make their own decisions it's
like go tell your mom that you're not
cool if you don't have this backpack and
it amps up as we as we go deeper down
the hole of it's it's clearly a
difference you know this suit wins
selling I don't need it it's it you
can't it's not that you can't markup
[ __ ] okay and by the way well that's an
insane markup from $7 $200 that's very
crazy but when you mark [ __ ] up that
high for kids and then your method of
selling it is manipulating them to beg
their parents that's a little strange
and it's so aggressive the marketing is
so aggressive and as I said before I
really do think it's a psychological
warfare between these brothers who are
so competitive
probably deeply hate each other and
share the same audience that they're
forced to market more and more
aggressively to these guys you know they
probably compare numbers and they deeply
jealous and hateful of each other I I'm
almost certain that it's just a pure
pure violet wean them I didn't
this is another weird thing that goes on
here they're bragging about their wealth
in the videos you know I got that
blingle while simultaneously saying I'm
and I'm also why I have this bling is
because you're buying my [ __ ] don't you
find that strange thanks for buying my
backpack now I've got a Rolex it's just
yeah I don't know usually that you'll
see this stuff in hip-hop but they'll be
singing about other stuff it's like it's
so funny they're talking [ __ ] about
buying merch when you're when you're
bragging to the very person who made you
rich about how rich you are because
a wrapper they sell albums they play
shows but if you're like if you're so
like it's like going to patreon
supporters and being like man I'm [ __ ]
loaded please please continue supporting
me but they're kids they don't
understand
yeah they don't understand it right they
just think it's cool they wears Gucci
and Rolexes that I mentioned that I'm
single ladies just want to make sure
that you can still fantasize about being
with me even though you're 12 did I
mention that I'm single also what's with
the yes I do in church this merch is
appropriate for all occasions funerals
too Sunday's best it's the god Church
mean you think so
[Music]
what's wrong with Yahoo Yahoo people use
Yahoo last night Oh AOL certainly that
would be a good insult I have a yahoo
account essentially what I'm saying
[Music]
anyway you get the idea yeah I ripped
that merch yeah I'm proud to rip that
merch and so should you
you only have value to me if you wear
merch if I see you on the street and
you're not wearing merch I might spit in
your face I definitely won't think of
you as a maverick but the more merch
that you are wearing well that's more
Maverick and I'm probably more likely I
did mention that I'm single to
spit-roast with you
and I'm so I'm also so dope that I
cooked santa's wife and cream pie dinner
he's mentioned cream pie in mrs. class
yeah where's my mouse I keep losing it
all right so it's like yeah I mean you
see you see what's going on here now you
see in okay so up next basically we are
hitting rock bottom we're gonna take a
quick break
we've got Jake Paul videos up next that
is basically the epitome of what I'm
talking about so please don't go
anywhere we're getting juiced and spiced
up go cream pie your left one we'll be
right back thank you to the elder
scrolls legends for sponsoring this
episode the h3 podcast listen if you
know anything about video games you know
about the elder scrolls
you've played Skyrim please it's the
best game of all time and guess what the
best game of all time now has a card
game and even if you don't like card
games you're gonna love this cuz he
likes Elder Scrolls alright let me spell
it out this game is amazing it's a
thrill ela knows Shiism she's she's sick
of me playing this game you can buy it
on mobile I know that right and tablet
that's what I thought that's my
preferred
method it's free-to-play it's out on
everything Steam Mac iOS Android tablets
phones and other undiscovered and
uninvented devices I'm telling you what
our everything whatever alien technology
there's a brand-new story expansion
coming out on November 30th with 50 new
cards and 15 plus hours of new story
content make a Bethesda net account and
it works across all of your devices this
is what I love say you're playing you're
in the heat of the moment you get
dropped oh my god not like this you
scribe you cried in despair hold this
and you're like oh my god I can open it
on my cell phone use my 4G and continue
where I was nobody will ever beat me
unfairly again you see me rage you know
what happens you get disconnected
playing your favorite game please that's
not happening anymore that's how great
this game is twitch drops check out this
cute stuff
if you link your Bethesda dotnet account
with twitch account you can get free
stuff just for watching your favorite
streamer play the gosh-darn game the
games got unique features like Lane
systems monthly updates frequent meta
game patches they believe that a digital
card game should make use of it being
digital and have frequent changes that
make sense you're not like a
brick-and-mortar black Magic the
Gathering you you know but burn those up
and throw them out because we got in
digital baby this is 2018 almost but on
the real guys this is a super super fun
game it's free to play give it a shot
I'm sure you're gonna love it
it's fun it's multiplayer it's
competitive it's got all the moves all
the Slams and if you're fan Ella
squirrels you're gonna love this so
please consider supporting the Elder
Scrolls legends
it helps us and God bless you thank you
so much to sponsoring us my duties
duties do holder but I mean it as in at
the moment I've been doing my duties
what is up my duties that should be the
Hebrew version of dude Doody did you
know that there's a Hebrew name as
always cracks me up
I think eel is probably sick of hearing
me say there's a Hebrew man named
duty there's a bunch of guys walking
around Israel with their names duty
sound we're known that I think of ready
and there's another one that cracks me
up but I won't sit that's too much for
the show
all right next quick you guys know that
I am in love with this toothbrush quit
people have described it as the Apple
the Macintosh of toothbrushes I think
it's better than that it's just a great
toothbrush
you don't need an analogy or metaphor to
compute what great this is the queen of
Elizabeth of toothbrushes it's an
empowered way this is what is with this
toothbrush is an empowered female heroin
character and for more than one reason
Buzz's variant vibrates a lot but on the
real this is an electric toothbrush it's
gonna change your life one it's
affordable as heck these electric
toothbrushes I was in the market they
cost hundreds of dollars I'm like it's a
toothbrush this one starts at let me
scan 25 boom it's an excellent electric
toothbrush it vibrates you turn it on
and it counts down for you vibrates
every 30 seconds until you're done so it
ensures that you get a great clean brush
and chant people they'll show that off
look at this - Oh Mike Oh God but it's
it's strong it can endure that it didn't
do it it comes in I don't get it and a
tube you could put other stuff in there
good pack meats in there for lunch just
being industrious guys let me give you a
challenge and by the way if you go
through the page they get quick console
sh3 they say refill for free
yulik liners yeah special shout out hey
quip comes with a mount that goes right
on your mirror fitting seamlessly into
your daily routine do you see that there
what's the Mount Gila
oh it's this so you so you have glow
just sticks right on yeah that's that's
comes off oh yeah you got you just put
that on the mirror
it's just taped right now but yeah this
glues to the mirror so here's the deal
you're gonna get the best brush of your
life for twenty-five dollars and let's
face it you could probably use some
fresher breath and I don't mean that in
an offensive way everybody could and
that's why I love quit here that's
mounted on your eye mounted on the let's
mount it up can you see that you guys
hold that up to the camera look at this
man oh my god no it's way too
it's way too command alright clip also
offers an optional subscription plan to
bring new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three months scheduled for
just five dollars which includes free
shipping worldwide that means if your
ass is in well I'm not gonna make any
guarantees but it's worldwide I'm not
guaranteeing it like to get some [ __ ]
this I love this toothbrush I use it
myself it's featured and just about
every gift guide this year including GQ
Gibb Coupe is highly reputable and
Oprah's oh oh I love how this toothbrush
my friends list guys it starts at just
$25 right now go to get quick calm slash
h3 to get your first refill pack Ferrari
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack free at get quick
calm slash h3 it's spelled GT q uip calm
slash to h3
you won't regret giving this toothbrush
a try I guarantee it and you might get
some more kisses out of it too
thank you for supporting us and please
consider picking one of them up if
you're in the market for a toothbrush
and we just want to give it all another
announcement teddy fresh hats everything
that you can wear on your head
beanies caps it's all back in stock so
head on over to teddy fresh calm if you
need to cover that head all the hats
were back the Black Friday denim had was
there was a lot of demand so we brought
it back yeah
it's like my new favorite hat
i and the beanie that I'm wearing is
gonna be in like a month or a month and
a half t-shirts are coming back so new
drop is coming soon we're working on it
you can look like Sideshow Bob it's like
me with this hat if you have hair like
mine guys thank you so much to everyone
who sponsored us please consider
supporting our sponsors let's jump right
back in thank you thank you welcome back
to extra podcasts we are examining the
merch machine of Jake and Logan Paul now
we've looked at Logan's two videos now
let's take a look at jigs this is his
recent Christmas song it's from December
5th it's called all I want for Christmas
you can guess what it is
oh that he wants now in a way this one
is so over the top and ridiculous that
in a way I hate it less but he's still
at the end I just want to show you now
he's still at the end it's selling it on
iTunes and Spotify and you'll understand
how funny that is so here we go
[Music]
right out the gate my friends strap in a
[Music]
fight at merch by that merge by that
merge merge by that it's like in a way
he's almost lovable because it's just so
absurd there's no pretending here like
in Logans it's like more trickery like I
creamed pie Santa's wife so throw away
your backpack but here it's just like
bad at over but it's it's so nice this
[ __ ] is off the rails like it's not it's
like a weird one - oh my god / Jake Poe
fan / Jake Paul use the coupon code
oh boy percent off it's basic I'm joking
but this is a hundred percent of a
commercial and he still sells it on
iTunes imagine buying this on items
hasn't already paid for itself Jake can
you give them the song for free it's a
commercial it's crazy I just I can't get
over it I need to buy it on iTunes yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna need that song if I
can [ __ ] the merch bro is this song
merch getting a song be merch I think a
song is merch now I can't get over that
course by that merch buy that it's great
it just puts a smile on my face
hundred dollars free shipping y'all
there's not a single line in this in
this that isn't about buying merch
like the whole lyric is the FAQ and
shaping page that's funny five business
days five business days so be patient if
you don't get it 24-hour support if you
hate it so that's the line that we were
referring to that's it's a little it's a
little crossing the line there this will
it son Christmas in a miracle thank God
my merch has come we have to acknowledge
just how it's like he's he's in one
breath acknowledging that his fans don't
have money and that their kids like
fully owning that there's just no shame
there's no pretending anymore because I
think a lot of youtubers are comfortable
coming to well at any rate it's a full
admission and then beyond that he's
saying you don't have money you can't
afford it you need to get it from your
mom you need to beg them you need to
coerce them if your parents don't tell
you know tell call Child Protective
Services and tell him that they touched
you inappropriately
whatever it takes right he's like I was
reading the Jake Paul forum and a lot of
people said they had success calling the
Child Protective Services and pretending
that they were touched inappropriately
that worked for a lot of kids to get
Jake Palmer whatever it takes
maybe I stretched it a little bit but
you get the idea
[Music]
she gotta fire come on decider merge
back my best course 2017 I mean okay
he's full my favorite song over the year
this is the hottest song single why
isn't this billboards top 100 so this is
a full admission this this is these are
what his fans are these are the people
he's talking to him and Logan I love
that they put him in because it doesn't
leave much room for doubt that they know
exactly where their marketing to yeah Oh
Jay Paul merch my parents do love me the
kids will accept me at school this year
[Music]
[Music]
but I don't understand what happens what
happens so Santa can't there's people
about too much merch Santa cannot
deliver it all but he has an idea you
could tell me what it is
I'd appreciate he had a t-shirt cannon
it's oh you did apparently it's like a
ICBM shirt cannon intercontinental
ballistic sure say it looks like a
grenade launcher
kill them all I figured it out Santa and
at all let's let's wrap it up for
humanity right it's not time efficient
yeah but it's yeah Jake of all people
should appreciate hand delivery I'm
gonna buy this so then yeah this is my
favorite part
available now on iTunes and Spotify just
mat littmus yeah let miss you gotta love
that I'm talking about ruining a whole
word so that is pretty much the my
little my little peek into the world of
their merch factory and again there's
nothing wrong with selling merch or
repping March hell I'm sitting here and
full teddy fresh paraphernalia but
there's a way there's a there's a
there's a weird way to do it and they're
they've they're they're marketing to
kids extremely aggressively by to mark I
can't stop in my head I can't stop don't
buy my merch you know here's here's how
you sell your merch don't buy this
no I'm just trying to be you know a cool
guy so there so that's that's that's
basically there's a bonus track we're
not done but I just wanted to show you
guys where it came from because in the
first video what Logan is my hero
everyday bro hit a same kind of cuteness
about like leek and bio but it just
became a full-on throw your sack out
[ __ ] an ax throw your old sack yeah
it's just so aggressive I don't know I
mean am I am i yeah can I get a Amen way
oh can I get a whale or an Amen from
somebody please a Amen I need I need
some hype man dude I need I need a full
crew of Heitmann mm-hmm Tay yes man the
[ __ ] out of me all day so what's the
bonus track so we've got a bonus track
that's not it's another Christmas song
by Jake Paul he made like 10 songs this
month yeah you made littmus with some
actual rapper who was it I don't know
his career is over now I don't ever know
he he seriously made like five to ten
songs all about Christmas month jus just
goes to show you how they crank these
babies out man so there's a there's
another one I really wanted to wash just
because it was so specifically bad and
it's not really very merch centric to
his credit but it's really something to
behold so this is a bonus track and it's
called twelve days of Christmas
everyone's time held favorite Christmas
song let's see this cover
[Music]
[Music]
because they do like they didn't post a
song a day yeah I don't know how it's
possible no they must really turn them
out they really have machinery here
there's got to be some really business
savvy capable people behind the scenes
really like doing some work yeah oh
dentists sang misses a whole album yeah
it's a whole Wow
it's basically a whole album dedicated
to selling merch it's unbelievable then
you buy the album it's like it's let's
back it up here now let me Jake baller
his songs are this is even limited this
is almost too much for me you're gonna
have to endure this particular one 12
times now my question to you Jake is
when you have this much trouble with a
note when you have that much trouble
with the no Anthony when you miss a note
that hard why would you make that the
one you say every time because it's the
lit bright you can hear the auto-tune
machine like smoking it's like heating
up to maximum power and you just do that
cut it it's just savage like not even
listen to the auto machine smoking area
me how do you miss it damn but the
technology I've heard people auto-tune a
fart to sound musical there's incredible
technology apparently it's not good
enough chants an ant the me it's crazy
it's like they just did it one take I
mean it's probably what happened but man
man oh my bro how did God bless him I
don't know what to say man god bless him
[Music]
thank you for making me rich go to fan
joy calm that's the thing I was talking
about like bragging about their wealth
while simultaneously marketing to the
people who made them rich strange also
look at this merch it's Christmas Day
bro okay it's like this every day bro oh
it's Christmas Day bro it's just you
just not a big baller no you're right
[Music]
it's the longest song all time someone
was asking in the chat what's with the
twins I was wondering the same thing
chanting it oh the baby the baby twins I
don't know they're really rough with the
Biddy Hef baby twins know someone ten
somehow there's twins I don't know how
to follow the whole drama it's like real
world I don't know everyone is going on
their lives but they're really they
really like mm-hmm tassel those kids
give him a good shake
seven British booties why the flippin
Hecker's glasses in his pants where he's
got yellers which is like these these
glasses you keep some under his
waistline like he's tucking his boner
under his I can't see ya you thick there
doesn't do a really good job there like
you see well you'll see that is the
worst one ever gave his seed Apolo gave
a seed what sorry what'd you just say
this dog donated sperm well bro I'm
sorry what this is like watching a recap
of Jake Paul last year we're learning
now they have twin babies he breaks I
began II got six bags of Gucci do you
know what giving your seed means it
means like what did he mean I feel like
I don't feel like there's any other way
to interpret that statement I mean I
don't like Apollo gave his seed that is
very very wild thing to put into a child
[Laughter]
a breeder oh yeah that's what he meant
he meant he gave his seed and the dog
they got a new pack they cropped him out
real fast
oh man hit those notes boy you're the
next big thing
[Applause]
bro you're not even close they have like
they have computers the size of NASA's
smoking and sparking trying to auto-tune
Jake singing right now I guess I did
some research because I was like what is
yello this is some like drug the kids
take like crazy on take well yeah it's
just yellow glasses well why did he have
them tucked under his belt line like a
[ __ ] nine reindeer twerking
progressively more sexual you notice
that's working the booties that's right
it has gotten it's like merch planting
seed twerking booties breeding dog spit
roasting cuties in Paradise and cream
pies mrs. Claus that's number 12
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa you can hear like fluctuating
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Taemin try and wear a legging
waterlogging
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
yeah nice one well don't forget to buy
this song on iTunes as well oh yeah
sorry I stopped it way too soon guys all
right well hey listen do your thing
get paid I don't know maybe I'm just a
whiny old man I thought there was
something interesting there
maybe I'm just a grouchy whiny old guy
that's a hypocrite who sells his own
merch - okay but I I'm sorry there's
something I thought there's something
interesting here I don't know why you're
all acting like I'm acting like
everybody already hated this getting
defensive already Dan was that was that
interesting is interesting but that last
one like physically hurt me well we
saved it for last yeah I appreciate that
I wanted idea I'm gonna overload
everyone too much by too much that's my
favorite merch I think that's the that's
probably my favorite one it's
wholesomely awful bad at merch anyway so
that pretty much concludes our season
one of the history podcast it's been a
lot of ups and downs a lot of it's been
all over the place guys it's been nice
we started here we didn't do a live I
was editing it at home and premiere with
five different cameras it was one of the
most awful things to add ever my my
computer was looking like an auto-tuned
machine trying to auto-tune Jake Paul
they just couldn't handle it it was way
too way too much information now we live
streaming on Twitch we've got a whole
team of people who support us who are
excellent wonderful people I'd like to
thank them you want you guys want to
come in here you want to go on like the
longshot how can I thank you guys on
screen coming here Dan you start with
Dan because you both switch
Ian couldn't make it today buddy I'm in
the chat oh yeah and the interns not
here so he'll remain anonymous forever
Dan our illustrious producer who turned
this dime-store gumshoe operation into
we got a table now we got some killer no
no seriously and this is that camera on
okay apparently not that gun whew
Janet Dan seriously shaped this [ __ ] up
he he did so much to help get this show
to a great technical point and thank you
so much
god bless you happy to have you so thank
you looking forward to working together
and ceasing to hell yeah and then there
is a more mysterious person that's true
we have Sarah I don't think you guys
have ever met her behind the switch
screen yeah she is the master switcher
switching means she switches the cameras
yeah there you're looking at yeah
and does the graphics too true stuff you
want to come out you Bible fact although
fact like there you want to just put it
on the lung and then keep your face in
Wow
yeah you guys can swap it out again so
thank you Dan thank you to Sarah come
say hi thank you for all the gracious
support work you put in god bless you
pleasure being here all those great
slick switches you guys right thank you
Sarah here so thank you very much thank
reshaped we need to make it 12 thing
later but with our people right on the
12th day we got Sarah man let Miss Sarah
switch the camp anyway thank you very
much yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you and he and of course the
anonymous intern and this is not here he
is the man who screens calls who you all
hate because he's so rude to you on the
phone I tell him to be so rude he does
he does a lot actually and listen for
that but he's not here he's sick
and let's see shraddha one more time yes
shredder of course Rick biggest round of
applause for transfer and everybody give
it up give it up I mean come on it's
Prince Reder
we're all here to serve shredder that is
the purpose of our life has just
becoming a giant that's it we're just
here to serve like I was saying in the
beginning we are going to Israel to
visit Ellis fam and to just think about
life a little bit as well you know
sometimes you just got to step away I'm
not gonna my objective for the first
time in so many years is to not work at
all I'm not gonna think about it last
time we were there we made a h3 video
who's a weird one or just because of how
like we forced ourselves to work and it
was just not right yeah ever B&B and we
tried to record in there it's weird you
know you need lights you need mic cuz
it's not it's not it's not right it's
hard to step away from your own work
when you're like your own boss sometimes
and so I think I'm just gonna step away
for the next two weeks I do plan to make
a vlog yeah we might go I like the
Israel phlogiston legs aren't they're
fun does don't feel like work we do a
little bit of thinking a little bit of
soul-searching and I'm we're coming back
season to strong we've got we haven't
forgotten about fishbowl it's a very
complicated legal matter and we've had a
lawyer working on it this whole time you
need some terms you need like how people
apply there's all this legal documents
we need and research done which is now
pretty much complete so that's something
we're gonna be digging into on season 2
which I'm very excited about and
possibly ramping it up to five days a
week which is gonna be nuts but I'm
I'm kind of excited my thinking on that
is just that it's new and exciting it's
fresh for me I love for example what
Howard Stern does he was like I love how
he his show worked and how he was just
there he was like like a companion to
people and he could talk about so much
it covers so much and I feel like I
really need a change and how I entertain
or do what I do and I'm and I'm thinking
maybe that's the direction I want to go
to try to try to do that we'll see we'll
see I'm thinking about it hopefully you
guys are excited about that idea I mean
if you're not if you're not well then
I'm just gonna have to you gonna need to
brainwash them I'm not I'm gonna have to
you guys are excited you guys if you're
not excited you're not a maverick
Ruth anyway to everyone who has watched
and supported us over this last year
this first season of the podcast has
been a wild ride and there's been ups
downs goofs gaffes laughs Rob spoofs
everything in between and your guys's
faithful support and viewership I love
so much when we run to someone on the
street and they talk about that they
watched our most recent podcast
to me that's incredible it's so
interactive and you have to be so
engaged to sit down and listen to a
couple [ __ ] knocking and so it's
surreal to think that people actually
sit at home and watch someone watching
this right now this you guys up there
it's weird but thank you yeah I mean
thank you so much um so yeah we're
really excited to come back with season
2 gonna get a little bit of a rest so
we'll see you guys January 19th that's
when we'll be back I hope you guys have
an excellent amazing new year I hope
that 2018 is a productive happy
fulfilling year for you guys and wish
you all the very best thanks for
sticking around and giving me giving me
something that making my bitching valid
because otherwise I just be I be a does
is a man complaining and the woods still
complaining it's like the old it's the
old proverb
alright guys we love you we appreciate
you we will see you next year
and with that I say God bless
thank you everyone guys in this weekend
and a great new year and please hurry on
over to fan joke oh hey guys order over
a hundred dollars and get the free
shipping by to tell your John but I keep
doing that and then tell you things -
yeah if they need to buy it all
Lincoln buy a free shipping off free
shipping goal anyway I'm done it's all
stuck in my brand forever
bad at merch yeah I just realized I was
I was in the bathroom I was looking at
myself in the mirror and I'm like I look
like such a [ __ ] idiot making fun of
their merch cuz I never wear this much
merch in a video this was like the one
shirt I had I'm sorry but fresh is not
merged that's true well I mean isn't
kidding it's fine you can call it it's a
mean between the memes you anymore hmmm
does shredder have a ghost stories
shredded you have any ghost stories we
need to end this dan can you put the mic
up to shred wait Dan and Sarah do you
have a ghost story
oh my god you guys have ghost stories or
UFO I'm afraid I'm a non-believer
you said you ignore me I knew that about
you Sarah and underreport okay I mean
yeah cool a bunch of skeptics now we
know at least that's why you work and
put the mic up to shredder really fast
yeah okay
it's happening okay good I can't see so
just let me know and then I'll shredder
do you have any ghost stories to report
have you seen any paranormal activity
everything's paranormal to him he
doesn't understand anything
Ian said I'm a ghost and I couldn't
agree more Ian is he's our usual UFO
doesn't have paranormal experiences he
is a paranormal experience all right I'm
very excited about next season so I hope
to see you guys there
love you this is your dick tiny little
vibrating too quick not calm especially
all right and different basic would you
do me a favor and end the stream and
what up - Shawn Oh what up Shawn all
right Shawn stinks on Twitch is it over
now you know is it still on
[Music]
[Applause]